so one of the downfalls of the election
of Donald Trump has been a lot of
grifters who have emerged in the
so-called resistance quote-unquote
resistance that have there honestly have
really found a way to enrich themselves
and to make themselves famous in there
let's just say ostensible opposition to
Donald Trump I say that because I think
they really appreciate Donald Trump
because he has made their careers but I
digress one of those grifters is in
trouble yet again Michael avenatti has
been charged with conning stormy Daniels
out of $300,000 I want to read a couple
of tweets that came directly from the
Southern District of New York attorney
general's office because ironically
enough they took to the same platform
that Michael haven't had to use to make
himself famous and they took to Twitter
to announce that he was now going to be
arrested and indicted quote US Attorney
announced this indictment of Michael
avenatti for aggravated identity theft
engaging in a scheme to defraud a former
client u.s. USA Berman Michael avenatti
abused and violated the core duty of an
attorney the duty to his client has
alleged he used his position to steal a
trust to still in advance on the clients
book deal as alleged he blatantly lied
to and stole from his client to maintain
his extravagant lifestyle including to
pay for among other things a monthly car
payment on a Ferrari far from zealously
Express representing his client avenatti
as alleged instead engaged in outright
deception and theft victimizing rather
than advocating for his client it was
always something about that guy's
character that really struck me as as a
conman I mean immediately when he said
he wanted to run for president I was
like oh this would be interesting but
you know hustler is a hustler
I mean there's really not much more to
say about that but I think most people
saw it and the problem is that sometimes
hustlers do a good thing I mean I have
an odd II did actually
bring forth some evidence that led to
the arrest of our Kelly so you know not
all the time I mean sometimes a hustler
can be useful but usually there's more
bad that they do than good and it's
we've seen this is not the first time
he's done something extremely criminal
there's a an amazing piece in vanity
vanity fair comm that really gives the
background into the last trouble that
avenatti got into using his power and
his influence his followers on Twitter I
mean Twitter followers is a really
powerful thing especially when you're
taking on the President of the United
States he has nearly a million followers
on Twitter and he used pressure from his
Twitter presence and his ability ability
to wrangle media to basically extort
Nike and to attempted to extort them out
of twenty two point five million dollars
for him to quote give them full
confidentiality and ride off into the
sunset and for that you really have to
read this piece of Vanity Fair because
they described you know I didn't even
realize it but they described how as he
was on his way to the meeting with Nike
he tweeted out about the scandal that
was happening with allegedly happening
with Nike and as he went up the
escalator to go to that meeting and he's
smiling at the number of retweets and
the likes that he got and and all the
buzzing that's happening on his fun
phone you know he's getting those
endorphins firing all for you don't Amin
because it gets a good feeling to get
5,000 retweets that's the best feeling
in the world for a sociopath like
Michael I have a knotty as he reached
the top of the escalator the FBI was
there to arrest them and that was that
was that so we have a con man who
affiliated himself with the resistance
quote-unquote resistance who made
himself famous as a result of his
opposition to Donald Trump and as it
turns out he is nothing more than a
two-bit con man just like Donald Trump
maybe that why that's maybe that's why
he was so good at opposing Donald Trump
but to his not to his credit but there
was a quote he said that I think it was
worthwhile in Vanity Fair he basically
said that
you know I was like Icarus I flew too
close to the Sun it's a good quote but
you're still a con man Mike